j'ai l'impression que c'est chez home
ils se sont trompés de slogans au lieu
de dire innovation for everyone
ça devrait plutôt être pourquoi faire
simple quand on peut faire compliqué
encore un nouveau smartphone de chez
home is et le million y
alors on récapitule parce qu'il faut se
rafraîchir un peu la mémoire ça se
complique regardez vous avez vu 11 vous
avez 2011
vous avez le million vous avez le
million vous avez 2011
vous avez le million et on a aussi du
flou ça fait beaucoup 2011
en l'espace de très peu de temps alors
je vais vous débroussailler un peu tout
ça nous on a déjà parlé il ya quelques
jours à peine il ya quelques jours du
million ultra le million ultra c'est le
plus haut de gamme c'est le gros
smartphone
on a également parlé du mir au mieux au
standard le million le million classique
on a également parlé du million zlight 5
g c'était également il ya quelques jours
et une fois de plus j'ai fait une vidéo
dessus et aujourd'hui on va se consacrer
sur ce smartphone la leumi 11/10/2011
yves lemire 11e le mieux est donc là
mais on dit il est intéressant il ya
également d'autres smartphones dans la
gamme bio ce vous avez le million light
qui lui par contre sera 4g alors on
pourrait se dire que ça une chose mais
pas exactement et y en a un autre c'est
le mit aux pros alors le million ce pro
et on va le ce bar est directement parce
que on ne l'aura pas enlever rappaz on
l'aura pas en france on l'aura pas en
europe a priori c'est un smartphone
qu'on n'aura pas donc celui là on le
prend à l'oubli le meilleur 4g je ne
pense pas qu'on en parle déjà parlé du
news line 5 gs qui me paraissent bien
aujourd'hui on veut des smartphones
samedi donc pourquoi regarder un
smartphone 4g mais voyez ça fait
beaucoup de propositions
ici vous avez un smartphone à 399 euros
90 quasiment 400 euros ici vous avez un
smartphone à 1199 euros donc quasiment
1200 euros et au milieu
au milieu de tout ça vous avez un
million à 749 euros 90 voyez peu entre
les deux et là on a mis lyon ziki lien
situé ici qui est le smartphone dont on
parle aujourd'hui qui coûte 699 euros 90
ça veut dire que là j'ai un écart de 50
euros
est ce que pour cet écart de 50 euros
j'en ai réellement pour mon argent chez
sur wii c'est ce qu'on a essayé de
comprendre aujourd'hui
[Musique]
en réalité c'est pas exactement ça parce
que sur le million si vous êtes sur une
version 8 + 2 156 à 699 euros tandis que
sur le million vous vous êtes souris
version 8 +128 à 749 si vous voulez
arriver sur une version 8 plus de 156 et
bien ça vous coûtera 799 euros et donc
un écart de 100 euros là et de 50 euros
là à vous de voir ce que vous voulez ce
bourg stockage dedans déjà 128 go de
stockage ça sera pas mal mais c'est
drôle quand même d'avoir des smartphones
aussi proches dans cette gamme de prix
alors effectivement semi 11 il est
plutôt court à leur regard des fêtes où
vous détailler mais il ya forcément des
concessions qui ont été faites pour
arriver à tarif un poil plus bas mais on
n'est pas un tarif 150 euros plus bas on
n'est pas un tarif à 200 euros plus bas
non si on voit tarif qui est vraiment
plus bas eh bien on vient chercher sur
le million the lights 5 juin là il ya
une différence significative là il ya
une différence qui est pas très
significatif entre le mit aux et le
million zid on quitte à mettre 700 euros
dans un smartphone est ce qu'il vaut pas
lieu a ajouté 50 euros de plus pour
arriver sur le bios plutôt que le mien
aussi
bon ça c'est la question ici en termes
de look franchement un million et un
million six cent soixante quand même
beaucoup alors celui là que j'ai voyez
il a un vrai miroir donc on se voit
dedans donc je peux vous parler
directement les yeux dans les yeux comme
ça on se voit ça c'est sympa pour trouve
bien ce module photo là donc ça ça
fonctionne c'est un grand classique ça
prend là la poussière c'est assez
incroyable mais bon capteur d'empreintes
digitales sur le côté qu'il est
verrouillé extrêmement rapidement
il ya plein de petites animations si
vous souhaitez moi j'aime bien à ça
comme ça je te laisse pas c'est très
chouette ça j'aime beaucoup c'est
vraiment un smartphone qui est super
sympa l'esthétique est très belle on est
dans cette gamme millions de 2021 bon
voilà il arrive bien d'un goy vous
racontez là dessus l'expérience est
quand même globalement la même on va
retrouver votre petite caméra de celle
fille qui est planqué sur l'eau ici et
qui marche bien on a un tout petit
menton ça marche ça fonctionne il n'y a
rien de bien surprenant le smartphone
est très joli et marchent bien ok donc
il ya quelques différences malgré tout
il ya quelques différences le poids
c'est le même l'épaisseur c'est pas la
même ici l'épaisseur elle est un tout
petit peu moins épaisse un tout petit
peu moins épaisse je joue vraiment à pas
grand chose une différence qui est assez
intéressante c'est qu'en fait il si vous
avez un corning gorilla glass pour mieux
le protéger ok ça c'est sympa sauf
qu'ici on n'est pas sur un rictus on
n'est pas sur la septième génération on
est sûrement de sixième génération mais
pas ainsi
dumas tease c'est un cinquième on a un
corning gorilla glass 5 c'est-à-dire
deux générations précédentes
ça c'est le premier point au niveau de
l'écran ça va être sensiblement la même
chose vous avez ici un écran amoled
vous avez un 6,67 pouces contre 1 6,81
booth au lieu d'avoir un double vécu à
jeudi plus vous êtes sur du full hd plus
a déjà une différence ici vous avez
effectivement un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz adaptatif
ok ça ça marche
vous avez un taux d'échantillonnage
tactile keira moins loin vous n'êtes pas
à 480 m autour des chantiers relâche
tactile mais à 360 certes on est sur une
dalle samsung qui marche bien qui est
bien maîtrisée ici est ce que maintenant
le fait de sourire
au lieu d'avoir un wqs des plus eh bien
je suis sur du full hd
bon voilà ok il ya effectivement une
petite différence ici mais bon ok allez
ok ok acceptant passons au niveau audio
c'est la même chose exactement la même
chose
j'ai beau avoir une expérience thériault
je la trouve pas dingue dingue dingue
j'ai préféré l'expérience sur le 1010
pro avant ça je voulais déjà dit je
trouve que là dessus xiaomi reculer
c'était beaucoup mieux l'année dernière
c'est pas mauvais mais c'est pas aussi
bon donc ça c'est un petit peu dommage
mais on reste vraiment dans la même idée
entre le million et le million y là
dessus pareil en termes de performance
et la même chose on a un instinct dragon
888 on a 8 gigas de ram c'est là le pdr
5 sera parfaitement bien on à 128 ou 256
go de stockage en ufc trois points sans
pareil c'est à très bien on a un modem 5
juin donc de la 5g
on est très actuelle donc pour
expérience de gaming c'est quasiment
pareil
la batterie à quelque chose près on
passe de 4600 millan père heures à 4500
20 millions par an il ya une différence
par contre au niveau du bloc de charges
à savoir qu'ici vous avez un bloc de
charge de 33 watts ici c'est qu'à une
petite différence contre 55 watts de
l'autre côté on va devenir recharger un
peu moins vite points de vue expériences
logiciel c'est pareil on tombe sur me
wade douce basée sur un android 11 la
même chose à taez différence au niveau
de la photo
et ça ça m'intéresse assez alors mise à
part le fait qu'à moi j'ai un vrai deux
miroirs je peux bien faire un coucou ça
va donc la voyez j'ai mon premier
capteur j'ai mon sens 8 mégapixels c'est
mon grand angle est là et si moi j'ouvre
af 1.75 ok donc j'ai instruit mégapixels
y 608 mégapixels sur le million il n'y a
pas grand chose à raconter les astuces
hairaz ya par contre une petite
différence au niveau l'ultra grand temps
qui est planqué là là où j'avais un 13
mégapixels et ouvre à f 2.4 ici j'ai eu
8 mégapixels touvre f 2.2 j'ai une
petite différence j'ai par contre
toujours de la macro ici bon 5
mégapixels et g
toujours la même caméra de celle fille
qui est planqué juste là c'est à dire
une vielle à pique celle qui ouvre à f
2.45 contre 2.2 avant maintenant il
différent ce qui pour moi est assez
importante quand même malgré tout c'est
qu'ici vous n'avez absolument aucune
stabilisation optique oct
aucune une stabilisation optique chez
nous ça s'appelle de l'eau y est ce ça
il y en a pas et ça c'est dommage parce
que ça change un peu l'histoire
ça change un peu l'histoire pour moi
déjà qui tremble naturellement ça va
être tout de suite beaucoup moins précis
ça change l'histoire sur la photo de
nuit bien évidemment parce que comme
vous n'allez pas voir cette
stabilisation est bien tout de suite ça
risque de bouger un poil plus et ça sera
un peu moins bon donc ça j'aime déjà un
peu moins pendant opère quelque chose
c'est quand même important sur un
smartphone aujourd'hui sur un smartphone
haut de gamme
je reconnais moment où j'ai fait les
photos le temps n'était pas
extraordinaire non c'est très saturé on
est dans des photos qui sont signés
xiaomi un grand classique on voit qu'il
ya une différence effectivement niveau
de la colorimétrie autres du dragon
temps les le capteur principal lutte
racontant les très saturé un quart des
voix ce verre comme il est versé à ces
élus sinon quand même c'est très très
poussif une différence là dessus qui est
bon ok on se rapproche ensuite on n'a
pas de téléobjectifs dudek on se
rapproche enfin de force à quai jusqu'au
x 10 et bien on voit courir sur le
capteur principal on naissance en 8
mégapixels qui va venir croquer dans
l'image x 2 on peut mais au delà c'est
pas terrible dit qu'on aura des emplois
cinq là tout de suite on a beaucoup de
bruit et une fois de plus le problème de
la stabilisation optique ne va pas venir
stabiliser votre image disque si ça
bouge un petit peu ça bouge à l'image de
ce qu'ont choisi de toute façon on
oublie c'est pas terrible donc on va
dire que jusqu'en x 2 on peut faire
quelque chose on va dire que le
grand-angle et bien l'ultra vente en
électro saturé et on va continuer à
regarder un peu plus loin kad merad
selphy le traitement je trouve pas
d'albane dingue c'est un peu poussif
mais une fois de plus là dessus rien de
bien surprenant grand-angle safra le taf
retrouve tous content et très saturé au
niveau luttera devant tant que c'est
très bizarre même le ciel regarder il
devient bleu leurs cahiers plus blanc et
ensuite on vient se rapprocher un peu
bon voilà x 2 on peut et après c'est pas
dingue hein c'est pas dingue et on le
retrouve un peu partout c'est toujours
un ami de toujours la même façon ça vous
chante
une fois de plus la caméra de celle
fille ici bon ok ça fera que tu as vite
fait mais c'est pas dingue et la macro
on a du mal en soi la caméra de
maquereau de toute façon droit aucune
stabilisation c'est clair mais ici c'est
difficile il faut vraiment venir se
caler pas bougé pour russe
avant quelque chose mais vous connaissez
mon point de vue les photos en macro sur
des capteurs dédié de 5 mégapixels s'est
jamais dingue c'est toujours difficile
je ne suis pas sûr qu'un usage plus plus
plus plus et c'est pas on essaye on peut
trouver des choses mais c'est pas dingue
voilà si on veut on peut mais on n'ira
pas très très très loin
ensuite on a regardé les photos de nuit
alors c'est dur comme on a aucune
stabilisation optique son capteur de 8
mégapixels et bien on le voit tout
regarder dès que ça bouge un peu aussi
imprécis c'est pas terrible ses moyens
et c'est très difficile de sortir des
photos de bonne qualité donc bien que le
grand-angle quand vous avez de la
lumière que sa chute vite ça va bien ok
fois de grâce au capteur 108 mégapixels
on peut au delà c'est pas gégé et je
préférerais bien évidemment mon bios 11
qui a cette stabilisation optique et
qu'il ira un peu plus loin maria
pression de vraiment le must
il faut aller sur le mieux aux ultras
mais ça c'est une autre histoire et un
autre tarif on a après le grand
classique wifi si sein des fc ça marche
ok donc vous voyez il ya quand même ces
petites différences où on va se dire ok
là j'ai deux générations de retard lâché
sur du full hd ou d'un double deck hd
plus là j'ai pas de stabilisation
optique j'ai une batterie qui a un poids
de plus petites j'ai quelques petites
différences alors si vous mettez les
mêmes configurations ensemble face à
face c'est-à-dire 1 8 256 vous avez 100
euros d'écart donc pour 100 euros
d'écart voyez on vient quand même
c'était quelques petites choses il ya
des choses qui se passent
on pourrait se dire que c'est minime
peut-être mais moi j'ai tendance à me
dire ok aujourd'hui ce smartphone allez
on va regarder une fois de plus on va
repartir sur le million le million
aujourd'hui je vous le dis si on part
sur la même config il est à 799 et
l'autre côté sur mon millions si je suis
à 699 euros
ok ce qui est sûr c'est que les
smartphones y bouge des tarifs bouge
dans le temps au tarif auquel joue le
prénom c'est sûr que tout de suite au
moment où je me présente c'est ce tarif
là mais d'ici très peu de temps ça aura
bougé donc est ce que ça vaut le coup
aujourd'hui de venir se positionner sur
un million zip pour 100 euros d'écart
sur les versions 250 gigas et sur 50
euros d'écart avec la version 128 sur le
million et 256 sur le million si je suis
pas sûr je suis pas sûr parce que les
gamins gap c'est quand même vrai
bénéfice alors c'est pas le corps nu
d'aurillac victimes parce qu'on vient
les protégés cela clairement mais wqs
des plus c'est intéressant ce cas même
point qu'à vraiment mis en avant je suis
au milieu dessus le fait d'avoir cette
stabilisation optique sa porte quand
même quelque chose c'est pas la grosse
différence au niveau
racontant que c'est pas la grosse
différence au niveau la taille de la
batterie est aussi une différence au
niveau de la rapidité de charges c'est
des petits points voiliers qui font que
ces 50 euros personnellement je viens
les m je viens les mettre pour aller sur
le mur versus le music dites moi vous
est ce que vous feriez ça est ce que ça
vous intéresserait
est ce que vous avez acheté le million
est ce que vous attendez est-ce que vous
hésitez entre le million et demi ont
aussi marqué moi ça en commentaire
personnellement je suis timide 11
j'aime bien le million s'y met avec cet
écart de prix qui n'est pas suffisamment
énorme je préfère apprendre un peu plus
je peux faire et sur lyon ce n'est pas
ce que vous en pensez en bas aux
commentaires dont je vous embrasse une
maison il ya très bientôt
ciao